das Tesla Model 3 im XXL Test
sportlichkeits Platzangebot
Beschleunigung tatsächlich Reichweite
und und und und und wir haben im
Praxis-Check alles getestet was uns
eingefallen ist echt alles die ganze
Leistung die kann er gar nicht mehr
abrufen um wirklich die Peakleistung zu
erfahren dass wir hier mit ganz vollem
Akku unterwegs sein und das haben wir
jetzt nicht mehr nach ein paar schnellen
Runden und ein günstiger Van mit sieben
Sitzen sieht ganz sympathisch aus oder
aber was taugt der Dacia Jogger wirklich
[Musik]
super oder das ging mit dem Touchscreen
nicht
und los geht's mit meinem Lieblingsthema
Tuning und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
mal ein paar Exponate die mir besonders
am Herzen liegen wie dieser Käfer aus 65
herzlich Willkommen zu Autobild das
Magazin die neue Fernsehsendung mit
allem was über Autos wissen wollt wir
checken High End Sportwagen bis hin zu
bezahlbaren Alltagsautos und
Elektromobilität darf natürlich auch
nicht fehlen
[Musik]